[Music]  kendall Jenner is slang in silver in NYC  I mean Agathe Kendall stepped out for a  vogue dinner at st. Ann's warehouse in  Brooklyn on Monday night the 21 year old  reality star stuns Kendall left little  to the imagination in a skin-tight  silver wrap dress revealing major  cleavage and a thigh high slit that  showed off her supermodel legs are you  kind of triangle for what's up  whatever's most unique and different  katie is giving us Kim K vibes pulling  her hair into her sister's signature  slicked-back ponytail she's my little  twin soul she kept her accessories  simple with a clutch statement rings and  metallic strappy Hills her body really  is the accessory  [Music]  you